[Music]
foreign
shark that was seen in the trailer of
the second Meg movie was estimated to be
around 55 meters or 180 feet in length
it is twice the size of the main shop
from the first movie this Megalodon
survived in the trench ecosystem for a
long time and there are theories that it
is still the same one that developed the
T-Rex from the prologue or the initial
scenes of the trailer dating back to 65
million years in the past but even if it
was seen as a truly enormous and
gigantic specimen it's still not the
biggest sea monster in movies and now
let's take a look at others that are
bigger than it
number 15 firstly we have the mutated
crocodile called Lizzy from the movie
called Rampage she is roughly 200 feet
or 61 meters long and therefore would be
a comparable size to the Megalodon but
only slightly larger than it it would
also be curious to have them side by
side in a crossover battle but that's a
wish that might never come true
at 14 we have the redosaurus from the
bees from 20 000 fathoms this is a
marine and underwater dancehall that was
awakened and attacked New York City it
has a length of 200 feet of 61 meters
and would be of a similar size to the
Meg and the same as Lizzy from Rampage
30 in the sentient alien whale called
Tolkien from Avatar to the way of water
so it measures around 300 feet or 90
meters long as a mature adult specimen
these asapian creatures that have an
intelligence that far surpasses humans
or the blue Navi of Pandora they are
however generally peaceful and
non-combative and thus would become food
for the Meg if they were in the same
ocean
at number 12 we have our first Kaiju
Titanic Cellar from Godzilla king of the
monsters this quits a fell apart Titan
with a hot exoskeleton and long spiky
legs stand at a height and a length of
around 341 feet or 104 meters this title
would be almost twice as long as the Meg
at 11 we have the mythical Titan killer
called the Kraken from Clash of the
Titans and this one is around 400 feet
of 122 meters long it has a body similar
to Titanic Cellar in a way well at least
the lower part it also has powerful
massive arms that can fight with gods
and Titans to a standstill if need be
and number 10 we have the bewilderbees
so this is a dragon from the How to
Train Your Dragon movies this title
class Leviathan Dragon cannot fly but
its wings are adapted into fins for
swimming it is the largest dragon from
that movie franchise and measures 520
feet of 158 meters long so it's almost 3
times as big as the Meg
and number nine we have Zilla so this is
the Godzilla from the 1998 TriStar movie
and also from the 2004 final Wars movie
although he has a height of 70 meters or
230 feet his body length however from
head to tail would be around 600 feet or
183 meters mainly due to his crotch
posture that makes him look sure that he
is as well as his extremely long tail
number 8 the Monstrous Cthulhu from the
movie underwater so this is a behemoth
of a creature it is estimated to be at
least 650 feet or 200 meters long
although it doesn't have any psychic or
Supernatural powers like the old school
Cthulhu it however by its Alpha status
commands a legion of symbiotic creatures
smaller creatures that live on his body
number 7 the Sando Aqua monster from
Star Wars The Phantom Menace this is the
largest creature from the planet of
Naboo and is almost thought to be
mythical since it survives in the
deepest caverns of the planet's oceans
the Sandu Aqua monster is stated to be
650 feet or 200 meters long
number six so next we have the Godzilla
killer which is destoroya from the 1995
Touhou movie called Godzilla versus
destoroya although the height of this
crustacean monster is 120 meters of 400
feet tall its length however is almost
double at 754 feet or 230 meters long
therefore four times the size of the
Megalodon shark number 5 the G-Man
titanus Gojira in his master verse
iteration measures a height of almost
400 feet a 120 meters tall which is
similar to destroya from the 1995 movie
but his extremely long tail puts him a
bit longer at 800 feet or 244 meters in
length these however are not official
sizes but our expert estimation
at number four of course we have Manda
what kind of sea monsterless is there if
Manda the dragon type Kaiju isn't
included so Amanda from the 2004
Godzilla final wars is a long and
slender Eastern Dragon design but it is
also an underwater Kaiju and measures up
to 984 feet or 300 meters in length
at number 3 we have the kaijus so there
are various kajus which can be seen in
the Pacific Rim movies onibaba is a
smaller one which can be similar in size
to the Meg but others like Zlatan has a
standing height of 596 feet of 181
meters but the length is double of that
meaning 1200 feet or 362 meters long due
to the extremely long tails
at number two we have the carton so yeah
as we go up the list the Megalodon shark
seems to shrink and shrink and now with
these two lost entries the gigantic shot
would seem just like a cocktail shrimp
the Keratin from the dceu Aquaman movie
is two miles long or 3.2 kilometers
and number one we have the Cloverfield
monster although the juvenile clever
from the first Cloverfield movie is 200
feet or 61 meters that is roughly of a
similar size to the Meg the adult
however which is seen in the Cloverfield
Paradox movie is the biggest in here
towering above the clouds at an
estimated height or length of 2-3 miles
or three to five kilometers
and so that's that the 15c monsters
bigger than the Meg so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos right
here on this channel take care fam